comme chaque année la communauté
malgache a célébré comme il se doit leur
fête nationale
le 55e anniversaire de l'indépendance
est aussi l'occasion pour nos amis
malgaches de se retrouver autour des
traditions et de la culture du pays la
villa du département s'est parée pour
l'occasion des couleurs de la grande île
a accepté de participer à cet événement
dédié à la commémoration de la fête
nationale malgache
peut-être fait c'est pas seulement pour
célébrer ou fêter mais surtout pour
faire connaître un peu plus sur
madagascar et et développer le côté de
la diversité culture de culturel de la
réunion l'occasion pour les
représentants d'associations et des
collectivités locales de rappeler les
liens fraternels qui unissent notre île
et madagascar
il ya tant d'histoires surtout pour les
réunionnais que les malgaches
il ya un indien et historique donc de ce
fait il faut essayer aussi de rapporter
toutes les cultures qui est très très
riche de madagascar
parmi les invités patrick karam
président du conseil représentatif des
français d'outre-mer une soirée rythmée
par des groupes de danses et de chants
de la grande île on pouvait ainsi
découvrir des expositions d'objets
artisanaux symbole du savoir-faire
malgache
groupes se sont succédé pour une
ambiance de fête
une célébration qui a permis à tous les
malgaches de se retrouver ensemble pour
se souvenir de cette date le 26 juin
1960 date de la déclaration
d'indépendance qui a fait de madagascar
une nation à part entière